brossard saint-lambert c'est la banlieue
typique une circonscription qui comme
bien d'autres a été emportée en 2011 par
la vague orange
enfin le taux de voter pour le npd
c'est ça qui a fait la grosse vague puis
tout dans ce royaume de l'automobile la
question des transports et bien sûr une
des préoccupations nouveau dispensant
près le développement la torah qu'est ce
que ça va produire le fait d'avoir un
nouveau pont pile à l'augmentation de la
population avec la 10 30 et tous
automatiquement développe et sow mais il
y a un dossier qui revient souvent dans
les conversations
la sphère du niqab est tout seul ça me
touche au site ils viennent cible puis
exiger comme ça on est pas d'accord tu
vas pas aussi minoritaire je pense pas
sauf que plusieurs électeurs du coin
souhaite aussi un changement garde à
ottawa mon show va être positive et de
façon stratégique par les derniers
sondages pour essayer de tancer le
gouvernement
le gîte est prête à voter pour le npd
l'on dit que si les libéraux qui sont
eux qui mènent donc je vais adapter je
vais attendre je voterai pas de façon
anticipée je vais attendre 19 octobre
pour essayer de donner la chance à celui
qui le plus proche de remporter
ce qui est certain c'est que j'aurais
voté pour les trois autres plutôt que
celui qu'il aime le moment bref au delà
du pont et des problèmes de transport
le vote ici semblent parfois guidées par
des réactions émotives ou des choix
stratégiques et l'issue du scrutin est
bien difficile à prévoir
ici vincent maisonneuve rage au canada
brossard